the american invasion of afghanistan
began way back in october of 2001
in response of course to 9 11.
afghans were sheltering saudis who
committed the terror attacks
they were trained there the question is
why do we still have troops there almost
20 years later
and the answer is not for national
security reasons but because our leaders
see afghanistan
as a handy place to conduct a kind of
social science experiment the kind that
george soros might fund
our leaders believe afghanistan must be
bonded in submission
so that its culture changes maybe we
should bomb them until they accept
gender neutral pronouns
that may be one of the objectives over
at the pentagon
the latest evidence comes from vox.com
in a recent meeting that
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff the hopelessly over his head and
extremely liberal mark milley
got emotional during a meeting about
withdrawing from afghanistan we can't do
this milly said
if we leave afghanistan women's rights
will quote go back to the stone age
so even at the biden white house people
ask well what does that have to do with
our national security objectives
one white house official called millie's
little speech quote a lot more emotion
than substance and said it wasn't quote
super logical but there is a logic to it
and the us government the pentagon and
the state department both of which have
been hopelessly captured by the left
while we weren't paying attention
they've been implementing these plans
around the world and particularly in
afghanistan
a report last month from the inspector
general for afghanistan reconstruction
outlines our government's efforts to
achieve quote gender equality in
afghanistan
bet you didn't think that was part of
the mission did you you thought it was
defeating terror
no it was changing the traditional
afghan family structure
that was the real goal why is that our
business why is that our job
isn't that cultural imperialism shut up
we're doing it anyway
the report notes that the us government
has dispersed quote more than
787.4 million dollars for activities to
quote support
afghan women and girls now that doesn't
sound
bad everyone's for women and girls has
it improved their lives
has bringing third wave feminism to
afghanistan
been good for the people of afghanistan
there's no evidence that it has it's
caused
a lot of disruption the inspector
general's report notes
among other things that there is no word
for gender or gender equality in any of
the languages used in afghanistan
it's just not their culture we don't
care the inspector general also found
that our quota system for female
politicians in afghanistan but you don't
think we have one of those but we do
it hasn't worked in fact it's backfired
many of these politicians have never
even visited the provinces they quote
represent what the hell are we doing
and why are we using the military to do
it colonel doug mcgregor
is a combat veteran a former senior
adviser to the secretary of defense he's
been around this world his entire life
he joins us now to explain
doug thanks so much for coming on
tonight why are we using the military to
change the afghan family structure
well i know the justifications sound
lofty and moral but in reality they
fall flat afghanistan over the last 20
years has become the leading supplier of
illegal
heroin in the world the heroin
production
industry in afghanistan employs at least
four hundred thousand afghans
more people that are in the afghan
military and
security police so it's hard to take
that seriously i think the real point is
as follows
we have a globalist ruling elite in
washington dc
it now includes a senior leadership in
the pentagon as well as the state
department the intelligence community
people on the hill and they've decided
that wherever we can
we should always intervene we've
institutionalized intervention
interventionism and these interventions
can never end that once you intervene
you have to stay because
privately i think everyone knows that
the moment that you withdraw
or disengage a couple of things happen
number one
everything you claim to have achieved
falls apart instantly
and then secondly it puts the force
structure whether it's in the marines or
the army
or special operations command or
anything else at risk
so you have incentives in a perverse
sort of way
to do the wrong thing in perpetuity
but i mean it's our military we can't
allow this
and i know that you have fought against
this kind of thing for decades and i and
i really appreciate it
i'm glad to see you back on this show
douglas mcgregor thank you very much
sure thank you tucker